I'm Daniel Hujar and I'm a scout master with Troop 152 in
Kerry, North Carolina. This edition of the Scoutmasters
podcast is sponsored by backers like us. And now for you,
scout master
Shane Lehman is a scatter with the 63rd Ottawa group in of
all places, Ottawa, Ontario, Canada- And he offers us
this handy tip to stop bacon from curling in the pan. Shane
says the way that you do this is to take away their
brooms. I think that would work. I think if you took the
brooms away, bacon would definitely stop curling in
the pan.
Hey, this is podcast number 232.. Hey,
Hey, welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is
Clark Green. Wow, we're going to have a lot to catch up on
here. Let's take a look at the mailbag first. Patrick
Thompson is the scout master of Troop 1134 in Roswell,
Georgia, And he wrote to say: our troop has visited
Condor Stakes several times in our short troop life. We're
reliving our visit through your dispatches. Big fan of the
scout master blog. We love the Condor Stakes dispatches-
Incredibly difficult place to explain unless you've been
there. Thanks for bringing memories of that daily
international jamboree back to life for our folks. Well,
thanks for getting in touch, Patrick. If you haven't been
keeping up with us. we got back last week from a long
visit to Condor Stakes International Scout Center in
Condor Stakes, Switzerland, And I have a lot of the
emails are going to be mentioning that And I've
got some other things to talk about that can. concerning
that trip, as we go on, heard from Harry Schneider And he
said: congrats on your retirement as active scout
master. Yes, Thanks, Harry, It was. it was a busy
summer And that was another thing that happened this
summer And I don't think we've really addressed it on
the podcast as of yet. But hey, you know, stay
tuned. John Wiebeke from Carmel, Indiana, wrote to
say I was just in Condor Stakes for the 30th staff
reunion of the people I served with in 1984 and 1985.
We had 24 of 30 staff members return for from Australia,
one from South Africa, two of us from North America
and three from the UK. The rest were scattered around
Central and Northern Europe. What an incredible
experience. Wow, John, that does sound like a great
time. You're really taking your scouts to a
special place. As much as I love camp here in the
US, Condor Stag is really something out of the
ordinary. I guess the blending of all the scout
groups from across the different countries makes
it different, But the spirit of scouting is the
same. I'd love you to share with me your
itinerary for this trip. I may have to try and
replicate it. with my troop, We went to Halliburton
and Algonquin this summer. It was a great
success. We had a good turn of weather and
everyone is full of memories and adventures from
that trip. John sounds like you had a great summer,
just like me, And I'll talk a little bit more
about some Condor Stag plans in the future
after I've done with the mailbag Heard from
Major Richard K Luckett, who wrote to say
congratulations on your retirement as a scout
master And I hope you continue to share the
experiences you've had throughout your tenure
on the podcast and the blog. I and many
other people count on them. Well, Richard,
I'm certainly going to do that. I am. I don't
have plans on going anywhere. I'll tell you
that Kim Vatnidal is a scout leader in
Norway And he wrote to say: I am a
scouting parent and assistant scout master
for Norwegian troop. I enjoy your sight and
thoughts immensely. Our troop is more adult
lead, But through your material on
scoutmastercgcom, I've started a silent
revolution. As of next semester, the
troop will implement much of what of
the suggested structure for a boy led
troop? There are still some differences,
of course, but we'll get there.
Interestingly, I have recently been
chosen to take over scout master when
the current one retires next year. I have
one question asked: what's your thoughts
on using and adapting some of the
material found on scoutmastercgcom
for our troop website? It would be
translated into Norwegian for our
scout parents. Well, Kim, absolutely
thrilled that you found what we're
offering useful. Translate away Anything
that you find is on our website is
there to further the aims of scouting
And if that, if that can help you, please
feel free to use it. That goes for all
of you, by the way. whether you're
going to translate it into Norwegian or
Kentucky and or Californian or
whatever language suits, Please do that.
And, Kim, congratulations on becoming a
scoutmaster. You're jumping into the
much-vaunted volcano. It's nice and warm
in here and it certainly is exciting.
Thomas Kepley said I would love to
share with my troop information
regarding the Switzerland trip. Do you
have information about the camp and a
cost breakdown of the trip you can
share with me? I think some of our
older scouts would really enjoy a trip
like that. I've also heard that some
older scouts in our troop would be
interested in working as
counselors at some international camp
like this. Well, Thomas, I am going
to share something in this podcast
that I think will help you out with
that, And yours is one of many, many
emails that I've received asking for
that type of information, So stay
tuned. Shane Lehman, who gave us our
helpful hint about bacon curling at
the beginning of the podcast from 63rd
Ottawa in Ottawa, Ontario, Canada,
also said: first of all, let me say
you have great podcasts and I'll
listen to it during my commutes. I
tell all of my scouting friends to
listen and I think it might be
working. Well, you never know. You
never know, Shane, do you? Until you
try? It might be working indeed.
Carl Hale is with the Transatlantic
Council in troop 457 in Brussels,
Belgium, and he's their scout master.
I've been learning from your blog
since I agreed to serve as scout
master last year. Our troop has
camped at Kandersteg International
Scout Center too. I just want to
let you know I appreciate your
blog. I'm happy you were able to
visit Kandersteg. Well, thank you,
Carl. I'm happy I was able to visit
Kandersteg too, And it's always
great to hear from folks in the
Transatlantic Council. Queenie
Campbell is with Boy Scout Troop
and Venture Crew 84 in
Stewart Straft, Virginia, And she
wrote in to say: keep calm and
keep camping. Troop 84's motto is:
if it ain't damp, we don't camp.
Amen, Queenie. We ran into some
weather all summer long, But you
know what? We kept on going.
Julian Atkins is a scout master
with Troop 727 in Burlington,
Kentucky. I've been enjoying the
videos and the activity from
Kandersteg. I spent four years in
Europe and I've been through the
Swiss Alps by car before. It was
amazing that you had Daniel from
Camp Freelander in Loveland,
Ohio on the second video. Daniel
certified me in water rescue last
summer, So he's perfect for
Kandersteg. I shared the video
with boys in the troop and they
were amazed that Daniel, their
camp counselor, was in it and even
more amazed that there was an
international scouting facility in
Switzerland. Love the videos, Thank
you very much. Well, thank you,
Juliana. I figured that somebody
would recognize Daniel or at
least Camp Freelander, And it was
great to talk to the folks that
were serving on the Kandersteg
staff who were also scouts in the
US. Craig Dixon is with Boy Scout
Troop 682 in Poe, California, said
Kandersteg looks really cool. The
question I have is: how does your
troop pay for the trip. What kind
of fundraising do the boys do? If
everything works out, I may have
the chance of getting my boys to
Kandersteg someday. Well, Craig,
we're going to be talking about
that in just a minute. Finally, we
heard from Beth Bo who said: I'm
not sure how Scouter Bill ended
up with your dispatches from
Kandersteg, but he forwarded
to me- I'm Group Committee
Commissioner for the Seventh
Etobicoke Scout Group,
Venturer and Rover Advisor and
Sean's mom. Thanks for getting
Sean on the video and thanks for
the shout out. Well, if you
watched the dispatches from
Kandersteg, Sean from the
Seventh Etobicoke was working
at Kandersteg. We got him on
the video. and how about that?
I heard from his mom. Well, if
you haven't figured it out
yet, you know what I was
doing this summer. Well, after
we did a week of scout camp
with our scouts and it was my
last week as being the
scoutmaster for our troop
after 30 years, and I want to
say a big thank you to the
scouts and the folks who made
it possible to build a new
pavilion in our campsite that
now has my name on it. I was
very humbled and very
appreciative of that and a lot
of my old scouts showed up
and my friends who I worked
with at camp. It was a
wonderful, wonderful time and
I just want to take the time,
if they're listening, to say
thank you for all those
gestures of appreciation and
support that I received while
I was at camp. After we got
home from camp we had just
enough time to get the bags
packed and head off to
Switzerland, and my wife and
I were there for three or
four days ahead of our scout
group arriving and we had a
little bit of a vacation
ourselves and then the
scouts showed up and we were
there for a glorious week
at Kandersteg International
Scout Center. Now if you
haven't heard of Kandersteg
before or if you don't have
any idea of what it looks
like or what happens there,
there are eight videos at
scoutmastercgcom. follow the
link right there at the top of
the page to dispatch us from
Kandersteg. That gave you a
pretty good idea of what the
experience is like. This was
our second trip to Kandersteg.
Our first one was three years
ago and since I've been
talking about that trip three
years ago and this trip that
we took this summer, a lot of
people had written in and
asked me and you saw that in
the in the mailbag there You
saw several people ask the
same question: How do you
make this happen? How do I
get my group over there? Can
you give me your information,
your budgeting and things like
that? Well, yes, I can and
I'd be happy to do that. I
also want to tell you about
what I am contemplating, trying
to make happen, perhaps next
summer or perhaps in 2016.. I
want to get you over to
Kandersteg International
Scout Center. It's not a
weekend camping trip, So
obviously it's going to cost
a little bit of money, but
it's doable. if my guys and
my troop can make it happen,
can get the money put
together for it, It's
doable for your troop. The
second big challenge is
actually putting the trip
together and making it work,
And there's lots of heavy
administrative lifting
involved in that, and
Switzerland, while it's a
wonderful, wonderful place
to visit, is also
frightfully expensive. I
think it's. if it's not the
highest cost place to
travel, it's got to be
in the top five. So
being able to put a trip
together like this and
pull it off at a cost
for the average family,
be able to finance
something like this, it can
be a bit of a challenge.
After doing this a couple of
times, I think I've got it
sorted out to the point
where I'm going to be able to
offer an experience for
you and your scouts
to get to Kandersteg
and make it possible without
you having to bear all the
administrative burden of
making that happen. And
the way that would work
would be that I would
have a couple of weeks
open next summer to
have groups come through,
give them a place to stay
in Kandersteg, make sure
that they were well fed
and help them set up
a slate of activities
that is both exciting
and adventurous.
I mean, imagine all the
natural beauty and wonder
of the Swiss Bernese
Oberland where all the
wonderful snowcap
mountains are,
and the fellowship of a
world jamboree,
and you'll begin to
understand
what kind of an experience
this can be. I mean,
the Bernese Oberland
is a world-class destination
and the village of
Kandersteg is right
smack in the middle of it.
It's home to Kandersteg
International Scout Center,
which has been there
for 70 years
and is a destination
every summer for
scouts from all over the
world, And I would like
to offer you the
ability to get there
with your scouts
without having to bear
the administrative burden
of putting it all together
and administering a schedule.
Now, if that's something
that interests you
for next summer.
I am working right now
on setting up
two weeks on the calendar
next summer
where we can make this happen.
If this is something
that honestly interests you,
if you're really interested
in seeing if
this will work out
for you and your scouts,
I want you to again
in touch with me.
Within this two-week period
I have room for
just over 100 scouts
and adults
to come and experience
the things that a trip
to Kandersteg International
Scout Center offers.
So here's what you do:
Email me, Clark
at clarkegreen
at scoutmastercgcom,
Put in the subject line
Kandersteg
and let me know
that you're interested
and I will keep you up
on this whole opportunity
as things develop.
If there's a sufficient amount
of interest,
we're going to go ahead
and we're going to make
this happen for you.
And the next point
of business here
on the podcast this week
is to answer
some email questions.
They've been piling up
since we took a little podcast
vacation,
So those answers
are going to take up
the rest of the podcast.
Hey, so let's get started.
shall we
Write me a letter?
send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer
to one of your emails.
Jerry Curry is the
Scoutmaster, Troop 15,
and he wrote in to ask:
I was listening to a podcast
the other day
and I think you mentioned
that you do all the sign-offs
for requirements
for star rank and higher,
while Scouts do first class
and lower,
And I was wondering
why you switch around
like that
for the higher ranks.
I try to keep this
as much in the Scouts hands
as possible
and only the Senior Petroleum
can provide a sign-off
for a Troop job,
because
all the other Scouts
report to him.
Well, Jerry,
that's a good point.
I'd say we don't really
have a rule
about this sort of thing.
It just kind of works out
that way most of the time.
You describe what usually
happens.
I consult with the Senior
Petroleum about signing
the position of
responsibility requirement
and I spend some time
with the Scout
discussing the experiences
as it relates
to the other requirements.
Jerry then asked back:
how do you have them
prove that they've been
active?
Do you use the Petroleum
book or a logbook
for attendance
at meetings or outings?
Well, I asked them
if, in their opinion
and on their honor
as a Scout,
they've completed the
requirement.
I asked them to tell me
why they feel that they have
and in 98% of the cases
we agree.
Now if we don't agree,
then we discuss
our differences
and how to resolve them.
I don't really have
a magic formula for this
other than saying,
instead of me trying to
assess the requirement
for myself,
I have a discussion
with the Scout
that begins with:
tell me how you
met this requirement,
what evidence do you have
that you met it,
and I let them tell me
exactly how they have.
and, like I said,
98% of the time
it works for me
and we're done.
I don't really have
a magical formula for active.
I don't have a metric for that.
it's a case by case basis,
because every individual
Scout's life
is going to be slightly
different.
they're going to have
a slightly different schedule.
you know reasons
for not attending
some things
and I want them
to talk about it
and I want to be able
to share my concerns
with them
and they can
share their concerns
with me,
and that seems to work
pretty well.
and we don't keep attendance.
we don't have a log book
or anything that keeps attendance,
so we don't have it
to refer to. anyway.
in another email,
Jerry asked me:
what advice do you have
for planning the yearly calendar?
well, it seems to be
the best way for
that this works to me
is once you have
the yearly calendar
laid out,
begin to think in quarters.
they need to have
three months of outings
pretty well in the can
and ready to go.
once the outings
are in the can
and ready to go,
then you have
the meetings that
lead up to them
and if,
in our case,
we have
directly after
the weekend
that we have an outing,
the patrol leaders council
meets
instead of having
a troop meeting
on that night
and we also
have a border review
on that night.
so usually
it's about
three meetings
that they have
to plan
in advance of an outing.
get everybody
ready to get
on the outing,
then we're camping.
but if they think
in quarters about this,
three months
have to be ready to go.
the next three months
are in development
and that keeps us,
you know,
roughly four to six months
ahead of the curve,
most of the time
in ideal situations,
and you know how often we
experience ideal situations.
but
that's my best advice.
it's heavy lifting
to get a whole year
of meetings planned
at one go
and you know
there are going to be things
that are going to interfere
with that plan
and you're going to have to
change it anyway.
so
if you can stay
three to six months
ahead of the curve.
you're doing a pretty good job.
Dave Scott
is with Scout Troop
710 in Bowling Green, Kentucky,
and he wrote to say
I'm familiar with
the way that we do
scout camping in America.
I wonder how they do
things like this
in Europe.
we have,
you know,
your average scout
with a highly structured
schedule of activities
and merit badges and things.
but I have read
about a troop that
does their own
outpost camp
doing just their own
troop directed activities,
and I also read
in one of the recent things
you published,
written by Baden Powell,
that he recommended
that kind of outpost style camp.
do you know what the rest of the
world leans to
as far as this goes?
Dave,
as far as I can tell,
the BSA summer camp
experience is a pretty
unique one
in the world of scouting.
there are very few packaged,
highly structured
summer experiences
at a facility
like a Boy Scout camp
where everybody goes
and they go through
the same experience
each and every week.
most of the rest of the world
does what you describe,
that kind of outpost camp
where they go to special
scout centers
like
Condersteg International
Scout Center.
so the program
is not quite so structured.
it's a little more open-ended
and troops are generally
pursuing their own activities
rather than doing them
en masse
as we're used to
now. I like that style
of outpost camp,
but I know that the tradition
of going to your local
scout camp
runs pretty deep and strong.
I know it runs
that way in my troop.
I think it's up to us
to make the most
of that experience
and include as many
of the
outpost camp type things
as possible.
for instance,
make sure that
you're running the patrol
method during summer camp.
make sure that.
make sure that
the patrol leaders council
is very active.
don't let the camp schedule
squeeze all that out.
but even in the most ambitious
camp schedule,
if you're a wise scout master,
you can find ways to build in
some of the
aspects of that outpost
kind of camp experience.
Ari wrote to say
hi, I'm a life scout
working on my Eagle project.
do my non-scout friends
have to obey
the power tool
rules
if they help me with the project?
well, I think so,
Ari. the way I see it,
the safety rules for Eagle projects
apply to anyone working on it
with you,
whether they're a registered scout
or not.
now,
that's my opinion
and I don't see anything
that says that specifically.
so to get a really good,
authoritative answer,
I want you to email the folks
at advancementteam
at scoutingorg
and there's two reasons
that I think
that this is a good idea.
first of all,
if they don't know
that question is out there,
they don't know to include it
in the next revision of materials
that are offered for Eagle scouts.
second of all,
they're going to give you a good,
authoritative answer
and they'll give it to you
in less time than I did.
took me a couple weeks
to get back to people this summer
because it was camp
and was traveling.
but the volunteers
at advancementteam
at scoutingorg
they do a real good job
of getting back in touch with you.
so that doesn't only go for Ari,
that goes for any of you
have a advancement related question
and you can't really figure it
out from reading the materials
that you have.
advancementteam
at scoutingorg.
they're pretty good
at getting back to you
and answering those questions.
and Ari, by the way,
good on you for working on Eagle.
Christian Kowski is
with Pack and Troop 168
in Crystal Lake Illinois
and he wrote in to ask.
my older son recently
crossed in the Boy Scouts
and I've been asked
to be the advancement chair
for the troop.
my question is:
what's your vision
of what the advancement chair's job is,
and do you have any
tips or tricks or suggestions
for somebody in that position?
I enjoy listening to your podcast
on my commute.
thank you, keep up the good work.
well, thank you for getting in touch,
Chris.
the first thing I would say
to any advancement chair
is to make sure you get a copy
of the guide to advancement 2013
and read it through
now. you'll do the same thing I did.
you'll probably skip over things
that just aren't in your bailiwick.
I mean, if you're a troop advancement chair,
you don't need to know all the details
for venturing
and sea scouts
and cub scouts,
but
you want to look through the book
really carefully.
you don't need to know everything in it,
but you'll want to know
where to find answers
when you need them.
I would look with a highlighter
and note all of the passages
that tell you why
we do advancement.
there's a lot of them in there,
and knowing the why
behind the how
is very important.
the mechanics and the rules
and the regulations
aren't anywhere near as important
as understanding the why.
as a matter of fact,
I don't think you can properly apply
the rules and regulations
without understanding the point
behind them.
most scouts who study the why
behind the how,
discover that there's probably
a couple of things
that they need to change
their thinking about.
if you find things like this
in the guide to advancement,
I suggest that you embrace them.
it takes some time and experience
to get it all down
and to build your own confidence
in addressing questions
and situations that arise.
you'll understand the mechanics easily,
but getting the why behind them
can be a little more nuanced
now. I'm always happy to answer your questions
and, as I just said,
the folks at advancementteam
at scoutingorg
do a really good job of that too,
and I'll answer anybody's question
about just about anything
if you'll email me,
and you're gonna find out how to do that
in just a moment.
thank you so much for listening
to this 232nd edition
of the scoutmaster podcast,
and here's a big shout out
to pack 232
and troop 232
and ship 232
and and venture crew 232.
here's how to keep in touch:
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
subscribe to receive updates
by email.
if you haven't already done so,
get the scoutmastercg app.
thousands of people have it.
it's available on google play
or at the iTunes app store,
depending on if you're a member
of the android tribe
or the apple tribe,
but you can use the app
to stay in touch.
you can send me messages
through the app.
you'll get all the podcasts
and all the blog posts
right there
and all the videos that we create.
you can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
join about 6000 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
tweet along with the chorus of
oh, i think it's about 1100
tweeters on twitter
and pin the pultritudinous pictures
proper publicly
with 1600
other prolific pinners on pinterest.
you can also watch us
at scoutmastercg on youtube
and or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle
on google plus.
now, look,
not all of us can face facebook,
and twitter makes some of us better.
not everybody has an interest in pinterest.
if you don't put the? u in youtube,
if you're a minus
when it comes to google plus,
don't worry, bunkie,
that's all right.
zoom into the late 90s
and send me an electronic message
by email.
yep, you can email me,
clark green, with your comments,
questions and wild ideas
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
it's c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom.
remember, if you're interested
in kondersteg 2015,
put that in the subject line of the email,
so i'll know and i'll keep you
apprised of updates.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not now,
nor have they ever been,
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
and they are not indoor store sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America-
or any other scouting organization
throughout the world for that matter,
because i'm sure they have
much better things to do with their time.
hey, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
before we leave
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping
bye. thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.